speaking of jojo like the you have like
the jojo kimono
right that thing is so i ordered that in
osaka
i would have ordered that i don't care
how much it was i'd have paid like like
not even a question i'm gonna find that
on yahoo auction yeah yeah
yeah that's where i get most of my jojo
emerge from yeah i'm like using google
translate hoping i'm not clicking the
wrong things
connor's become that stamp collector but
just for jojo's yeah yeah
his grandkids are gonna be like what
what is all what is all this
yeah cause when i when i have a call
with my parents all my merch is behind
me like what are those toys
what are those toys it's not a toy man
this is this is a one-sixth gyro
zeppelin
200 are you kidding me you just like
bust out the ocean like
you don't understand how pristine this
thing is right now
i i love getting deals for jojo's stuff
so much i also got jojo's smartphone
which i never use
right jojo's smartphone yes there is
judges no not like a smartphone skin
like an actual smile yeah from docomo
what what really why not this exists
where can i get one yahoo that's
probably one of yahoo yeah probably
there's so much jojo merch like you just
always like stuff blows my mind yeah i
spend way too much time looking for jojo
merch i know there's websites that are
dedicated to like tracking the release
of new jojo merch
really oh yeah and i kind of go because
they release so much all the time which
is
great you know being a fan i mean yeah
but sometimes there's stuff that's like
when would you ever use it like there
was there was one that was like
rohan kisube uh like tiny jigsaw puzzle
it was like it was like tiny though like
this and i was like
i mean like a four-piece jigsaw puzzle
what's the point like i'm never gonna be
able to like open this because i i'll be
scared to like
actually do it or like lose a piece
right yeah
it was something like 16. it was like
right like it's barely a puzzle yeah
there's just other stuff like
i don't know i have no interest in clear
files but i think japanese yeah
i don't know why the clear files is the
default okay we're going to release
uh merchandise to do with this to do
this show let's just make clear files
it's because it's
so cheap to manufacture right it's like
the youtuber like first t-shirt that's a
reference
yeah they just put like xd you know it
just seems like the most tacky thing
really ever and i i've never bought a
clear file but i've always been given
them
as like a gift or something and i i
don't know what to do with them honestly
i have a bunch of clear files but i i've
kind of bought it's it's so ironic
i bought a file for my clear files
so it's like you know the tree defeats
the whole purpose you know there's a
file
it's like it's like a little bit they're
actually like they're actually like
custom made
clear file also not so fast files for
your clear files because people know
that no one actually uses the clear
files right and they just treat it as
like a piece of like art or whatever
yeah they don't want to use it but they
need some place to like easily access it
and i found one and they sell it in like
daiso and stuff like that oh yeah it's
like 100 yen so i just bought
one don't they sell at daiso and so i
put all of my uh because i have a lot of
monogatari
uh series clear files right because if i
find something monogatari i'm gonna buy
it
so i just put all my monetary clear
files into my clear file file
to explain daiso is like the dollar
store here in japan where you can get
like
everything you didn't need every little
contraption
you didn't know that you needed until
you go until you go to the store
literally
anything you need for your house you can
find everything
yeah it's not that's so much useless
so how many files could you file in the
file
i think i think the one i bought i think
the one i bought you can put in like 20.
oh just looks like a lot you're like
right okay write this down yeah
20. yeah yeah but it's it's you know
it's nice like
right it's better than just having all
the clear files just scattered
everywhere
at least it's in one spot just don't buy
clear files
and just please stop making them
companies we don't care we really don't
care
clearly someone does yeah i mean because
you know you
have limited room you need to pick your
merch carefully you know and when people
like man
why is conor like being mean about a ten
dollar figure i'm like it takes up space
that space is for the expensive voice
yeah connor's trying to maximize this
i'm trying to make like the most
expensive jojo cabinet right
you're
[Music]
is it still open i think so yeah i've
just reopened it yeah yeah
the current team like you know yeah yeah
yeah that was for a long time but uh
yeah i think they
recently just started re-opening again
and uh man the collection there because
i went there for a video
and the collection there is nuts i i saw
so many figurines that i was like
wow i didn't know they made a figurine
of this character
and he had the uh he had that really
limited jojo
it was it was uh jotaro jotaro the
swarovski one
so it's like full on diamond encrusted
joe
and it's like i looked it up on yahoo
auctions it's like four thousand dollars
it's pretty expensive and he just had
one on like a pedestal that sounds
amazing
i was just like oh my god
i want to get it connor's about to spend
more money i'm like
i just i have to like not go on yahoo
auction because i will end up buying
something
that's why i never made an account on
yahoo auctions because i know i'm gonna
spend so much money
uh yeah i did but i think it was a
little harder they didn't accept my
cards and stuff but
i was like nope you probably need a
japanese card right for me i do yeah
now oh you do yeah i still don't i still
don't it's so hard to get a credit card
or a debit card here
it's i don't know what banks want um
i don't know how you got accepted either
because i got rejected the first time
but like in the uk they just basically
just like give you a card they're like
oh yeah
they just you just you just press this
button
oh for a debit card no so like a one
that actually so they rejected me for a
credit card
uh which i only thought there was credit
cards and then i got a debit card but i
needed someone to like help me fill it
out because
they don't offer english ones like forms
so i was like well
i'm [ __ ] what do i do i want to access
my money because i was using my foreign
card for like the longest time right
yeah god damn